investigators in the deadly Amtrak
derailment in Washington state are now
focused on speed and possible
distractions for the engineer they say
that he did not apply the emergency
brakes as a train approached a curve
traveling 80 miles an hour and that was
50 miles over the posted speed limit
David Beck knows in Dupont Washington
looking at safety technology David good
morning good morning Gil preliminary
indications are positive train control
was being installed on the tracks here
but it was not active at the time of the
derailment PTC is that program that
could have slowed down that locomotive
as it entered the curve here in Dupont
Washington PTC has also led some people
to say had it been active we wouldn't be
here talking about a derailment of
deaths crane operators have been busy
lifting the mangled rail cars that once
made up Amtrak train 501 off of the
interstate and onto flatbed trucks new
photos from inside the passenger
compartment showed the destruction
caused when the train derailed the
emergency brake was automatically
activated when the accident was
occurring rather than being initiated by
the engineer that suggests the engineer
never manually slowed the speeding train
before it crashed the event data
recorder shows that the train was
traveling at 80 miles per hour in a 30
mile per hour zone
among other questions investigators are
looking into whether the engineer was
distracted or impaired distraction is
one of our most wanted list priorities
at the NTSB the National Transportation
Safety Board says there were actually
two people in the lead locomotive cab
the engineer and another conductor who
was learning the new route both were
injured in the crash
friends and family members are mourning
the deceased including Zach Wilhoit and
James Hamre two local rail enthusiasts
who were on board to celebrate the
inaugural run of this brand-new line
lloyd flem is the executive director of
all aboard washington the advocacy group
that both men belonged to that's a
terrible tragedy a terrible irony
knowing that they left us doing what
they loved and doing what they had
for is a little bit of a consoling
feature there were cameras on board the
train they were damaged but they're on
their way to DC to be analyzed Anthony
look because those train cars actually
be railed and fell onto the freeway it
created a traffic nightmare even if you
don't drive here get this yesterday some
people waited in traffic for nine hours
one man went one mile in one hour
traffic experts were telling people some
of their best options were a 65 mile
detour high five is that important David
thank you very much David beg no